[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
ground control to major tongue
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
ground control to make it
seven six commencing
countdown engines on
to check ignition and make gods
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time to
this is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the door
[Music]
and the stars look very different
today
am i sitting in the tailgate
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thousand oh i'm feeling
very scared
and i think my
tell my spaceship i love her very
can you much me
can you hear me
can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
there's is i can do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for boys
[Music]
[Music]
town
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think
[Music]
maybe you'll get
[Music]
um
back to
[Music]
beyond
[Music]
[Music]
can you feel it coming in
hold on
i don't know who i am
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
i
know the reason
[Music]
the heart doesn't
you and show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is this the real life
is this just fantasy
[Music]
open your eyes
look up to the skies
[Music]
little
[Music]
to
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
all the way
is
this time tomorrow
[Music]
too late my time is
[Music]
goodbye everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nobody loves me
from this monstrosity
let him go
[Music]
me
so you think you can stop
baby
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
anyone can see
nothing really matters
to me
um
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
somehow i think you got to stop
[Music]
you really don't remember
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
hurry up but you really don't remember
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
when you're
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
i think they got the aliens
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blue jean
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets are gone
[Music]
is not that bad
[Music]
in their auditorium
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
the word she knows
[Music]
[Music]
and you can hear me
when i say softly
slowly
[Music]
count the headlights on the highway
[Music]
lady
[Music]
dance
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
now she's in me
in my head
when i say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
time to
[Music]
say
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time to say goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this marine one be advised on final
approach
[Music]
me
themselves
[Music]
i
[Music]
who will they send you down
oh
[Music]
am
i've paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
[Music]
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
of the world
[Music]
no pleasure cruise
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
are the champions
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
always in demand
anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
has changed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 45th president
of the united states
donald j
[Music]
i trump forget the men who died
who gave that light to me and i gladly
stand
up next to you and they've been first
still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to venet
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where it
and i is forget the men who died
who gave that life to me and i can't be
standing
next to you and defend her still today
no doubt
i love this land
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
next to you and defend her still
[Applause]
today
[Applause]
we tried to come in here very low-key we
wanted to make a low-key appearance
did anybody notice the helicopter flying
a little low and
real slow
greatest pilots in the world greatest
equipment in the world that's what we
have
greatest equipment in the world but the
greatest pilots
nobody can do what our pilots can do
right mike
hello pennsylvania hello
eight days from now can you believe it
eight days
started off four years ago remember our
meetings and our
it was a love fest right from the
beginning wasn't it and now it's more so
you know what it's more so than it was
four years ago
and they're gonna be finding that out
very soon
they're gonna be finding it out you know
i have i have the ratings right on me
poll numbers thank you
thank you very much
you know joe biden you know sleepy joe
biden said a little while ago he was
he was in a lid you know what a little
garbage can they put the lid on it they
put them
and he saw we had two of these today
there were fantastic different parts of
the commonwealth of pennsylvania right
and we had two events sleepy joe was
down there and they said you got to get
out of this basement
so he traveled from delaware to a little
tiny corner of pennsylvania like right
next to delaware
and he made a speech and he said that he
doesn't do these kind of rallies
because of kovid you know now he doesn't
do that because nobody shows
up that's why nobody shows up
covered kobenkova that's all they talk
about the fake news kovitkova kelvin
that's all they talk about what progress
we've made on it too we understand it
we know we have to protect our seniors
especially when they have heart
when they have diabetes problems and we
are protecting them we have the best
testing in the world that's why we show
so many cases because we do more testing
than anybody else
but we're doing great and uh oh excuse
me
here i am right i'm here for you
i didn't feel so good one day one day i
didn't feel exactly great
mike a great congressman but i didn't
feel exactly great and uh
i said what's the story doc sir you've
tested positive i said positive for what
doc tell me
and uh you know and i say this a
president
you're doing your job you can't stay in
the basement of the white house
you can't stay in a basement you can't
stay in a beautiful bedroom upstairs
you can't do that you got to do your job
and i i'd have many days i'd say
i met a lot of people today there's got
to be something going but one day they
came back
and these doctors were so great and
there are a lot of them there's so many
doctors you know when you're
president there's so many doctors and i
had 12 doctors can you believe it i've
never had 12. i've had one or two
but i've never had 12 and each one was a
specialist different parts of the body
and they would grab my body and i hated
it
i said get your hands off me doctors but
let's make me feel good and we took
something that was like
incredible regeneron and i don't know
maybe i would have just been perfect
just by doing nothing but who the hell
wants to take a chance
and i woke up the next morning and i
felt like superman
get me back get me back they hit me back
and the first lady had it right first
lady had it
she did great she's great she's and she
is popular
too people like her they love they love
melania
but she had it doesn't complain about
things
and then of course baron had it and with
baron
you know young strong immune system
he had it i said what's the story doc
with baron
sir he tested positive like 15 minutes
later how's baron doing sir
it's gone so you have to get
back to school we have to get back to
school
pennsylvania you know you have a
governor
you have a governor
you have a governor who doesn't you know
want
us to do anything in pennsylvania
because
did you see the poll just came out we're
up to and another one we're up for
[Applause]
because you watch i have a whole list of
the polls that just came out
but eight days from now we're going to
win the commonwealth of pennsylvania and
we're going to win
four more years in our great white house
just a few hours from now the senate
will vote
to confirm judge amy coney barrett
to the united states supreme court
that was a good choice was it i've never
seen any
i'm glad she's not running for president
i'd much rather go against sleepy joe
much easier now she's fantastic a
fantastic person fantastic woman
a great student her professor her great
professor at notre dame said
and he's been teaching a long time a lot
of great legal minds he's taught he said
she's the single
greatest student he's ever had that was
good enough for me that was a
highly respected person he's a highly
respected man he said sir she's the
greatest student i've ever had
judge barrett is one of our nation's
most brilliant legal minds she'll defend
our rights our liberties and our
god-given freedoms and you saw that
[Applause]
and we were all watching a great
amusement as she was so-called grilled
by the opposition that was easy right
that was easy that was like one of our
great football teams from the area
plenty of them
playing a high school football team that
was really something
judge barrett will be the third supreme
court justice
along with almost 300 right around the
number
by the time we end the first term
i'll have 300 maybe a little more maybe
a little less federal judges
that we've confirmed to uphold our laws
and our constitution
and part of that was that barack hussein
obama
allowed me to have 142.
we started with 142 empties i don't
think anybody's ever had one you don't
do that
but he left me 142 couldn't get him
confirmed
to this day joe biden refuses to release
his list of names gotta live
you know it's more than just a pack in
the court he's got to say who's he going
to put on
because we can't have radical left
justices that are going to destroy our
nation
and we will be very very careful as to
who we choose you know i left a list of
45
i had a list of 25 and now i added 20
names to all
top scholars top top scholars and amy
was one of them
took amy off and the fact is you have no
idea a lot of people say i won because
of the supreme court because
they didn't know who i'd pick and i gave
a list and i said i'll pick somebody
like this
and then they said that's not good
enough got to pick somebody
in that list so ultimately there's a
list of 25
all great scholars all people that
believe in something known as
the constitution if that's okay
[Applause]
i don't think his list will and
they say that that was a big part of the
reason that we won the election four
years ago
and he has to do the same thing he's got
to not only agree to not pack the court
or you can't put him on it would be
terrible terrible for our nation
even justice ginsburg said you can't do
that you can't have
nine is the right number we have a
senate
we have a house a lot of people nine is
the right number nine
great people that's the right number but
he's got to agree to not pack the court
but he's got to agree to give us a list
of five
or 10 or 20 or 30 or 40. got to have
people to pick from
and if you don't have that list you
can't vote for him and you can't vote
for him for another reason
because during the debate i'm sure
nobody watched the debate did anybody
watch the cookbook
remember the last question it was like
perry mason it was just like perry mason
it was at the end he was doing great
this guy was doing so wonderful not
really
meaning he was getting through and then
the last one i said
so you don't want oil joe well uh
yes we want to get ourself off of oil
and how about kristen who i thought
treated me good i really did i thought
she
compared to chris wallace much better
right
chris wallace i was fighting two people
but no i thought she treated us good and
frankly
she went in and she said why did you say
that to him
and that's when he really blew it so
basically he's not going to allow you to
frack and you have a million jobs in
energy jobs probably more than that
and it's a big part of our nation what
you do people don't realize that about
pennsylvania but fracking is a very big
deal
who are you pointing to
oh oh
look at that whoa
oh boy the coal miners right the coal
miner
dig we must dig we must clean coal i
don't call it coal
i call it clean call they can do more
with coal now thank you very much
remember when hillary she said we will
stop
all colemans we will never dig call
again
and then four weeks later she ended up
in west virginia that did not work out
well for her
that was not good remember she was
trying to explain that she was just
kidding
just like just like he's doing just like
sleepy joe's doing he was just kidding
but he's down and if that doesn't win us
but
we just had a poll come out we're plus
two now you know we've but we should be
a lot more than that
i'm not happy with plus two i don't like
buzzfeed it's an
honor you do a great job dig we must dig
wema
and we brought it back we're selling now
call to vietnam and many many places
from uh
are you coal miners from pennsylvania
good
good that's good well you're not going
to be voting for
joe biden
not like he's a sophisticated
environmentalist he was told to do this
our opponent's agenda is one of doom and
gloom and depression decline and despair
our agenda is one of unlimited optimism
we want to be optimistic remember during
the debate
he said it will be a dark winter no
it's going to be a beautiful winter it's
going to be a beautiful spring
okay our country is coming back stronger
than
anybody would have thought and you have
to get your governor to open up your
state what this guy is doing you know we
had one site where we had a site it was
a big site beautiful site and he made
sure that they didn't do it we had to go
around
scouting out for sites on offers this is
my third one all in pennsylvania
but this governor uh but we're gonna
remember it but the problem is how is he
going to be the one when he tries to
play games with sites
that counts ballots right he counts
ballots he's the governor
and then they sued us because they
didn't want to have poll watches you
know what a poll watchers
they watch you count the votes what's
wrong with that if you're doing it
straight
so we're in court and we had a
pennsylvania
judge who said oh you shouldn't have
poll watches can you believe that we
actually lost the first case but
we'll go up and we'll end up in the
supreme court the other thing they want
to be able to drag out the election long
beyond the third
well in all fairness this is a
very important place right and we can't
drag it out we don't want to drag out
any longer so we are in lots of court
having to do with this
and having to do with many states about
five of them
and so far we've had a lot of good
victories and we'll continue because
we're not going to let this election be
taken away from us that's the only way
they're going to win it
we're not going to let it happen for the
last half century
47 years joe biden has been outsourcing
your jobs
opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood and treasure
in ridiculous endless foreign wars
countries you've never even heard of for
the most part
now joe biden is trying to ban fracking
and deliver an economic
death sentence for pennsylvania's energy
sector you can't
you can't allow this to happen but
here's the thing for a year i watched
him saying
there will be no fracking right we saw
with the democrats right
the radical left democrats they're will
they're all screaming no frack in every
one of them they couldn't scream loud
enough
and he gets the nomination because
elizabeth warren pocahontas refused to
get out
how had she gotten out that crazy bernie
would have been our opponent
but i think i like joe better because
there's no energy
i liked you no bernie had a little
energy small base lots of energy and we
had a lot of his
people you know a lot of them with
crooked hillary
bernie he gets i i won't use it because
they have very young people here
he gets taken advantage of by hillary
and then he gets taken advantage of by
the democrats the last time with
mostly elizabeth warren and the others
they ganged up on him
and he goes back and he goes into the
senate i think he's the greatest loser
he's a really good
he's a good loser he's a good sport
crazy bernie
and in the last week's debate joe biden
confirmed his plan to abolish the entire
u.s oil industry that's right and that's
why kristin said why are you doing this
because she's on his side you know
because that's nbc
owned by conquest c-o-n not com
conn so she's on her side she's saying
why are you doing this if you really
look it's almost pleading
sir why are you doing this and i'm
saying just be quiet
that's what happens that's right that's
what happened to perry mesa remember the
guy was always great great great
and at the end i did it i did it it was
that was sleepy joe that's what
you don't need a president like that
that means no fracking no natural gas
no call no jobs no energy
no pennsylvania families being well
taken care of
fracking is saving pennsylvania families
2 500 a year at least
and it's saving families all over the
country we are energy independent and
you're a big part of it
and they want to end that they want to
go to wind
do you love wind a nice windmill right
alongside your house your house is now
worthless
you know when those windmills go up and
they're near your house i know a lot
about wind
it costs many many many times the energy
that we're talking about many many times
like 32 cents versus three cents
whether it's natural gas or other things
but many many times
but you put up a windmill if you want to
see a
bird graveyard go under a windmill
sometime you will see a gravel
you will see it kills your birds got a
lot of problems okay and it needs
subsidy massive subsidy
you don't want to be giving subsidy to
energy when there's no reason to do it
so he wants wind and he wants solar i
like solar too but it still isn't
developed and solar's not gonna power
your big powerful plants
which we have to have in order to
compete and beat the rest of the world
it's just not gonna do it and neither is
wind
and neither is wind he will eradicate
pennsylvania energy production
and send your state into a crippling
depression that's what's going to be
because energy's such a big
people just don't know that mike about
pennsylvania it's a big
big energy state be amazed you know it's
funny texas so
he's against oil he's against guns
second amendment
and he's against god so he goes and then
they say
president trump is four points up in
texas and the governor calls me from
texas great guy greg he said
sir that's not true you're up a lot
but they don't say that but think of it
you're against oil
we're in texas you're against oil you're
against god you're against guns
in texas guns in texas trump is up four
points it's a very close race
no no same thing here because you have
the same thing and you could really say
the same thing
almost to a little bit lesser extent but
the texas was just amazing
so that's why i said at the end texas
and pennsylvania i hope you're looking
and i hope you're listening and that
goes for ohio and it goes for oklahoma
and it goes for a lot of other places
so you know we had polls because the
fake news is always given fake numbers
you know they're called
they're really called this suppression
suppression pulse
so here here they are all brand uh
rasmussen did you ever hear of rasmussen
very highly regarded paul
so over there we're at 53 and 52
that means it's hard to lose you when
you're at 53 or 52.
so rasmussen where and that's national
that's not
you know what i'm doing i go to places
like hillary used to campaign
in california when it doesn't matter
although if i were california i'd vote
for trump because
the place is going to hell
i would vote for trump i would vote for
trump
taxes are too high crime is too high new
york
taxes are too high people are fleeing
crime is too high
i put out vote for trump remember
african-american i said the same thing
vote for trump
what the hell do you have to lose that
was last election now
we are doing so incredibly well with the
african-american the black community
and the hispanic community
no it's unbelievable they get it because
we did criminal justice reform we did
prison reform we did the historically
black
colleges and universities what we've
done opportunity zones with the great
tim scott
senator from south carolina we've done
so much
and now the black community is strong
with us we had a poll today
at 40 40. nobody knows what that means
nobody knows what that means that's a
number that nobody's heard of with
respect to the republican we should be
much higher than that
joe biden is a die-hard globalist who
wiped out your steel mills
close down your factories kill your coal
jobs outsourced your industries and
supported
every terrible and disastrous trade deal
for more than 47 years he was a
cheerleader for nafta
one of the worst trade deals ever made
by the way usmca just kicked in
it's great usmca is a great deal just
kicked in
your companies aren't going to be moving
to mexico or canada anymore
that i can tell you
biden enthusiastically voted for china's
entry into the world trade organization
decimating your manufacturing and
enriching
china at your expense and you were
really one of the biggest victims this
state
you lost 50 of your manufacturing jobs
after biden's nafta and china disasters
they were disasters
he signed it along with other people but
he was one of the people that
pushed it decade after decade vote after
vote
sleepy joe biden has betrayed
pennsylvania you know that
he repeatedly tried to cut social
security and medicare you didn't know
that until
a week ago when we started showing you
the clips
and that was bernie sanders is the one
that exposed him on that
now after years of economic treachery
he wants to ban fracking and he's going
to and what about his running mate his
wonderful running mate
they asked her about fracking she's only
said about 300 times
it will never be fracking now she said
no joe wants it right
but she said it was the harris biden
administration that's the first time
i've ever heard of that one
she came first no she's nothing special
she never was
i can't believe she was picked actually
nobody treated him worse than her
plus she was a disaster her poll numbers
were going so bad
she left before iowa right before the
vote her poll she started off at like
12 and then she went to 10 went to eight
went to seven went to five went to four
went to two
went to one went to the other she said i
think i'm going to get out of the race
and she treated him so badly what she
called him and everything else
and then he said i'd like to announce
that i'm going to pick
kamala to be my running mate you can
have them both you don't have to take my
word
we have joe on tape now i only do this
one and the
location's very important to me because
this thing cost a fortune putting up
this tape okay
but look at this crowd so you can watch
what joe says go ahead please roll the
video
my problem is i voted for nafta i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters when you ran
for president
and when barack obama ran for president
you both said you would renegotiate
nafta
you didn't trade agreements like nafta
and permanent normal trade relations
with china which forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an hour
has resulted in the loss of 160 000 jobs
the president is absolutely right when
he says
that china has been cheating for 25
years and that bill clinton
didn't do enough about it george w bush
didn't do enough about it barack obama
didn't do enough about it what how
exactly are you going to negotiate that
what magic wand do you have rising china
is an incredibly positive development
for
not only china but the united states and
the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
as our competitor we should be helping
the idea that china is going to eat our
lunch
is bizarre
china is going to eat our lunch
come on man they're not bad folks folks
china's
not a problem allowing china into the
world trade organization
which he supported extending most
favored nation status to china which he
supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open trade deals
against us do you think in retrospect
that you were naive about china no
today we're finally ending the nafta
nightmare and signing into law
the brand new u.s mexico canada
agreement
very special listen it's hard to
overstate the importance of the usmca
uh this is the single biggest bipartisan
legislative victory for this president
and this administration
it is a huge deal wage growth is better
than it has been since 2009
that means it is better than it has been
for seven out of eight of the years that
obama was president
the new usmca has powerful protections
to keep
auto manufacturing jobs since the
election we've created
41 000 brand new motor vehicle and parts
jobs
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the us mta is better
than that
it is better than nafta
never said i oppose frackie you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website i'll put it on put it on the
website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in the biden administration
no it would we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee we're gonna end fossil fuel
no more no new fracking
i'd gradually move away from frackie and
i think it's critically important on day
one
that we end any fossil fuel leases on
public lands
what about say stopping cracking and
stopping pipeline infrastructure
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil fuel
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking
i have one final what do you close down
or would you close down the other way i
have a transition from the oil industry
yes
oh transition
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma
so you never heard me say that that i
could tell you
now isn't that great it's a very
expensive deal but
it saves me a lot of work because
there's nothing does it better than that
right
a vote for biden is a vote to offshore
your jobs
ban fracking and deliver economic ruin
to pennsylvania to your families
in 2016 pennsylvania voted to fire
this corrupt far-left political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally
putting america first
[Applause]
[Music]
with your vote we will continue to fight
for american workers lower drug prices
you know what we're doing on drug prices
at the first year in 52 years where drug
prices came down prescription drugs last
year
but we're doing favored nations so we
pay the lowest in the world right now we
pay the highest
and the drug companies don't like me too
much i can tell you that they're
spending more on advertising than sleepy
joe
support our police protect our second
amendment which is under siege
[Applause]
defend our borders maintain energy
independence and ensure more products
are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa
right we will deliver record prosperity
epic job growth a safe vaccine that
quickly ends the pandemic and we're
rounding the turn they hate it when i
say it
with or without we have the vaccine it's
going to be great we have
numerous companies all great ones but
we're rounding that turn
anyway we're rounding the turn we
understand the disease
we close it up the greatest economy in
history we closed it up we saved two
million lives remember it was going to
be 2.2 million lives
we saved 2 million lives and we're
rounding the turn normal life
that's what we want normal life
we'll fully resume we'll never forget
what china did to this country or what
china did to the world
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country
and that's where we're heading if you
look at the job numbers
automobile numbers if you look at
housing i gave working families
record-setting tax cuts
and in my second term i will cut
middle-class
taxes even further to give you the
largest
tax cut the largest tax cut in history
this is the craziest campaign
right so all my life i watch politicians
running they always say
we are going to cut your taxes right
we are going to cut your i got a guy
running now
who sort of shot he goes we
will raise your taxes i say what the
hell
i said did he just say that yeah he's
going to give you the biggest tax cut
in the history of our country including
regulations and all the other stuff
which made it so good for us
this election is a choice between a
trump
super recovery or a biden super
depression and that's what you're gonna
have you're gonna have a depression if
you go with this guy
it's a choice between a boom and a
lockdown he wants to lock down your
country you're already
locked down with your governor wolf
governor wolf has a beauty for you
sure governor we trust you to count our
ballots governor we trust you
and it's a choice between the rule of
the people
or the rule of the corrupt political
class of joe biden and the
democrat socialists and that's where
you're heading
and i always said this country will
never be
a socialist country never ever ever
but if joe biden and his democrat
socialists are elected
they will delay the vaccine delay the
therapies
prolong the pandemic close your schools
they're already closed open them up open
up those schools
and shut down our economy
and we're doing we're coming back with
numbers like nobody has ever seen before
i tell this last week the end of last
week the atlanta fed projected gdp
for the third quarter just it's going to
be announced just before november 3rd
of 35 nothing ever
even close i think your record is eight
percent
eight percent nine percent 35 percent
that he wants to close it down not a
good idea joe
biden says he has a plan for the virus
and he doesn't he
just copied you see what he did he
copied our plans the same plan he copied
our plan
everything he's proposed my
administration has already done
including mass production of rapid tests
and
pp we've done and what we've done with
the ventilators is incredible
this we weren't prepared with
ventilators our hospitals didn't have
them
our governments didn't have them our
federal government didn't
we went into a production of ventilators
the likes of which
they've never seen anything like it
since the end of world war
ii biden doesn't know how to defeat a
pandemic
his own chief of staff said that when he
managed the h1n1 which he always
reverses
swine flu you know the swine flu a much
less
much less lethal flu
it was an outbreak we did he said quote
we did everything possible and we did
everything possibly wrong
we were a disaster 60 million americans
got
h1n1 in that period of time and it's
just purely fortune
that it wasn't a mass casualty he said
we didn't know what the hell we were
doing now this guy comes in
he should have closed it down sooner but
two and a half months later he was
saying i shouldn't have done the ban to
china i shouldn't have done the ban to
europe
if the h1n1 had the same fatality rate
as the china virus
over two million people would have
already perished based on the way they
ran it it was a disaster
and his own person said it it was a
total he said we didn't know what the
hell we were doing
and now he's going to come in and help
us this guy can't help himself
in an interview that aired last night
biden said he opposes letting young
americans
resume their lives which was an
interesting statement
99.98 of those under the age of 50
recover and most recover very quickly
but biden wants to keep them
locked down in their homes while letting
riders and looters run wild
so in pennsylvania you can't go to
church
you can't go to restaurants you can't do
anything right
but if you want to have a nice little
riot
if you want to have a protest that's why
we call everything a friendly protest
that way we're allowed to be
think of it you can't go to church but
if you want to burn down
center city we have no problem with it
i'll tell you
we're bringing our country back but do
you think it's easy with these people we
have to deal with
the biden lockdown would crush america
and my plan will crush the virus and
we're going to have a boom like you've
never seen before
like you've never seen before
when the china virus arrived we moved
heaven and earth to fight the disease we
banned all sorts of
things everything we could band we
airlifted
medical supplies built hospitals from
scratch
look what we did in new york the
convention center 2
800 beds then we put in the ship
unfortunately governor cuomo barely used
it
if he would have used it for our great
seniors he wouldn't have caused the
death of 11
000 people seniors and 40 000 people
overall
slashed red tape pioneered
groundbreaking therapies
reduced the fatality rate 85 think of
that
i think think of it i mean look at
regeneron for me
and by the way we're going to make
regeneron available to anybody that
feels they want it need it
same as i have free free
and the vaccines that are being produced
it's not your fault it's china's fault
we're not forgetting and the vaccine's
going to be free
it's going to be distributed free to
everybody
we will deliver 100 million doses of a
safe vaccine before the end of the year
maybe quite a bit sooner than that
seniors will be the first in line for
the vaccine
and our frontline workers too i will
break through
every obstacle which we've already done
use every resource and i will not rest
until we eradicate this disease that
should have never come
to our shores or to the shores of the
rest of the world
should have never come
never forget we will vanquish the virus
and we will emerge better stronger and
more unified than ever before
if biden and the democrat socialists are
elected
they will raise your taxes to a level
that you've never seen before
bury you in regulations dismantle your
police departments
dissolve our borders they don't want
borders they want open borders they even
said maybe we'll take down the wall
which is now
almost complete you know the wall is
almost complete just what the board
told border patrol i said give me the
best give me your specs
i said let me use concrete plank i want
to use concrete plank it's quick and
it's cheap
they said sir we can't do that we need
steel concrete and then we borrow i said
that's great
we gave them everything they wanted
we're now beyond
400 miles and it'll be finished very
soon
it's amazing it used to be all about the
wall they never thought i'd get it bill
used to be all about the wall because we
had the democrats would do anything not
to have remember
all the work and everyday front page the
war will not happen it will not happen
now that it's almost finished you don't
hear about the wall anymore right they
don't talk about it
the fake news media doesn't talk about
look at how many there are over there
too that's all
that's a lot of valuable equipment
that's a lot of that's a lot of valuable
equipment
and mexico is paying for the wall by the
way in case you had any questions that's
the other thing
so now they know it's built then they
said but mexico will not be paying for i
said no no mexico is paying for the wall
okay but
they'll figure that out very soon
they'll confiscate your guns terminate
religious liberty and destroy the
suburbs
women of the suburbs you must love me i
can tell you
i'm saving yourself i'm saving
i got rid of the regulation that was
going to destroy you suburbs
unless you like crime which you don't
like right they were doing a new thing
about three four weeks ago they said
suburban women don't like trump
he's losing suburban i said why wait
but that's only because i know two
things about
suburban women they don't want a
regulation that is brutal
that's going to build low-income housing
next to their house
okay they don't want that a project we
call it a project
and they don't want crime in the suburbs
and you know antifa
antifa says that's the next place they
want to head
they're not heading to the suburbs and
you know what
as soon as i say those words they want
law
order they want safety they want to have
their families be safe
and then they say about i think we're
going to do very well with suburban
women we have a lot of suburban women
right here
we got rid of uh regulation and ben
carson a great guy said well sir you
know be a lot easier we just amended it
made it a little
less onerous it's horrible it's horrible
with your zoning and they've changed
your zoning and you can do whatever you
want and
ruin everything i said no ben let's
terminate it well but if we do it'd be
easier now
ben let's turn it let's just terminate
it i said uh do it
he said that's a tough one but we'll do
it and we terminated it it's gone
now if if sleepy joe comes back you know
who's going to be in charge of it cory
booker is going to be in charge
cory booker the mayor of former mayor of
newark new jersey who never lived in
newark
i don't know how he got away with that
one mike never lived there
they will censor you cancel you and
indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lives but we don't let
that we don't let that happen you saw
that two weeks ago joe biden has made
a corrupt bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination
he has handed control of his party over
to the rage
phil socialists marxists and
left-wing extremists right because joe
doesn't have a clue let's not kid
ourselves
joe how are you doing joe not well oh i
got to say wait wait wait
so the polls right so winning 52
and 53 percent not bad right and that's
nationals it's
almost as you know it's crazy as it is
it doesn't mean anything
nevada trump is up by two texas
trump is up by four much more than four
remember
guns oil and god
i'm on this side he's on the other side
so let me ask you maybe even more so
that if a candidate is running in texas
and he said we are against oil i think
that's it right
but now add guns to it and now add
religion
and that's what they're doing they're
closing your churches your churches
are all closed it's terrible it really
is terrible ohio we're up big ohio the
great state of ohio
we have great people in ohio jim jordan
do we like jim jordan
ncaa wrestling chair people don't know
that about jim you know about jim
ncaa wrestling a real tough guy and a
great guy
florida we're up four just came out
just came out rasmussen georgia we're up
very nicely four or five but we're
really up much more than that don't
forget
if we're up four add another four or
five six seven to it
i'm not sure i'm proud of it but people
don't want to talk about it right they
don't want to talk but they vote
arizona we're up in arizona we're up in
iowa
we're up big in montana well montana
we're up really big
we're up in utah and we're up 22 points
in west virginia west virginia
oh but you don't hear this when you
watch because there's suppression
they want to give you negative stuff
their suppression they're very dishonest
people but that's okay
they were dishonest last time too worse
actually right but you got to get out
you got to get out and vote we got to
put this thing away we win pennsylvania
we win the whole ball game
[Applause]
so just you know you're known as a late
voting state right
very late which is a good thing who is
going to vote
soon
[Applause]
who is going to vote on november 3rd
yeah one of the few right yeah you want
you like
you don't like a ballot sent out and
then thrown into a garbage
now you know you're known for it's
called smart people
who is going to vote for sleepy joe
biden
only if you have the courage only if you
have the courage to raise your head
please don't do it
who is going to vote for president trump
[Applause]
all right now we're going to have a big
you know they call it the great
red wave and they're waiting for it you
know all these ballots came pouring in
these crazy ballots are pouring in from
all over they send the ballots out
nobody knows who's sending them who's
receiving them who's signing them
you know they want to have a thing in
nevada where you don't have to prove
signature you know minor things like
that right
but they're going to have a wave and
they're all saying about the red wave
but i think the great
red wave is going to be much bigger than
people have any understanding about
i think but you hear those numbers you
don't hear those numbers when you watch
the fake there's a suppression
they want to make you nice and depressed
so you take your wife or husband you say
you know i really like the president but
he can't win because i listen to
fake cnn or i listened to fox fox
by the way fox has the worst polls of
all and they had four years ago do they
have the worst
i said they have the worst you hear that
john roberts who i like a lot
they have the worst he's right there hi
john
they have the worst poster of anybody
fox is terrible they got it so wrong
last time
but you listen to these polls and you
say let's go to dinner darling and then
we'll go home and
sadly we'll watch television but you
know what happened four years ago
everyone said no we're not going to
dinner we're going to vote
right hillary with her statement about
the deplorables right the deplorables
well the deplorables decided
that was incredible was that incredible
when she said that who would have
thought that was so bad it was the forms
she actually said a worse word than that
right the irredeemables remember she
said
the deplorables and the irredeemables i
thought irredeemable was worse than a
deplorable right
but it didn't catch on the thing that
caught on was deplorable the next day i
was making a speech like this
and it came out it came out we are
deplorable
and they came out by the millions that
church sold like crazy
the fake news you know every time that
happens and now it's happening with
biden because that's a crime family
franklin
but every time that happens when they
say lock her up lock him
they always blame me and i have nothing
to do with it i'd mention the name and
the place goes crazy they said
you incited that i said i didn't even
talk about you see that
fake show last night 16 minutes i did a
good job that was a very hostile
hostile attack by a woman that knew
nothing if biden wins the flag burning
radicals on the streets will be running
your government you know that
look at portland we want to go into
portland so you know we did a great job
if you look at seattle we said we're
going in
and the night before they said okay
we're leaving now
because you know we have to be aston the
federal government has to be asked
and then we did a great job in minnesota
minneapolis
i mean they should have told us to go
there a week and a half early would have
been nice it would have saved
a lot of destruction remember the cnn
anchor velci
he said we are here they don't want to
talk about riots because it's bad for
them you know
we are here in a peaceful demonstration
and behind him right over here the
entire city is burning down
right they had a fire that looked like
berlin
on its worst day the whole place was
burning down
and then he said the military has formed
well it was
you know it was a great group of people
you saw that the national guard
and it was one two three all of a sudden
they started
one line two lines and they just marched
forward
that tear gas didn't velcy get hit on
the knee with tear gas and he went down
they said he's down velci i don't even
know who the hell velchi is i just
remember
did a little shave job on his head i was
thinking about doing it
i was going to do a little but i decided
against it i didn't want to go down 25
points in the polls
ali velshi he got hit on the knee with
tear gas right and he went down
and he uh he was not the bravest guy but
i'll never forget the scene of him
saying
this is a friendly protest and behind
i'm telling you i never saw fire like
that it was the craziest thing but we
did a great job we sent in the national
guard and the national guard
it was over in what half hour max they
just started walking
world's most expensive uniforms their
helmet costs
like a giant computer they just
and you know there was something very
nice about it after watching what went
on for a week and a half
but all of it we could solve it all all
they have to do is ask us the federal
government
is waiting and it's always run by
democrats new york problem run by
democrat
chicago problem how do you like her as a
mayor is she wonderful
run by democrats all run by democrats
this election day the people of
pennsylvania need to defy the corrupt
media the big tech machines and you look
at what they're doing they're protecting
they won't write anything negative about
a man who is corrupt they won't write
there is nothing they will allow to go
in
and the forces trying to keep you down
and hold you back it's the most
incredible thing and i give great credit
to the new york post to endorse me today
by the way
because they're the only one with the
courage to do it and they're out there
it's great
what they're doing you must stop the
anti-american radicals from
doing what they're doing you can't let
the democrats and joe biden
have a far left a victory this has to be
a thundering defeat not just a defeat
it has to be a rebuke a rebuke of
socialism
and as corrupt as he is and all the
things he's
his son is like a vacuum cleaner let me
follow you into
china dad dad i'm gonna be managing
one and a half billion dollars have you
ever done it before so no i haven't yet
i have no idea they've never done a deal
like that china doesn't do that they
don't give other people money to manage
but you know the scary part is that
remember the big guy gets 10
right the big guy he's the big guy i
don't think he's the big guy the big guy
gets 10
and the big one with china was they
wanted 10 million a year
for introductory purposes so 10 million
i wonder what that was all about that
sounds like a reasonable number then
ukraine
183 000 a month to sit on a board
of an energy company with a questionable
reputation
sit on the board and he has absolutely
no knowledge of energy this young person
sitting right here
very young knows more about
energy than where's hunter i call
hunter's real first name is where
where's hunter
remember we made the t-shirt
joe wants to send your jobs to china
while his family rakes in millions and
millions of dollars from the
chinese communist party oh they want him
to win
can you imagine i'm charging him
billions of dollars in tariffs
joe said he would take those tariffs off
of me billions i gave 28 billion to the
farmers in iowa nebraska all of the
farmers
because they were targeted and joe wants
to take the tariffs off i gave him
remember i i 25 dumped steel they were
killing our steel companies
25 and our steel companies have been
doing great now
if biden wins china wins when we win
america wins
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician if
that's okay
and i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder than anyone
has ever fought for you before
[Applause]
you think this is fun i had a good life
before this i had a nice
beautiful i could go anywhere i could do
anything thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you very much you know that's a
chant they say they've never ever heard
in politics i won't repeat the chant
because i don't want to cry you'll start
crying now they'll say
president trump broke down in tears
today
we are joined today by a couple of
warriors real warriors and
great people these are people that have
been with me day and night
fighting this movement this horrible
left
radical left movement congressman john
joyce
congressman g t thompson
great people and a man who's so popular
he was with me the other night different
location
was about 30 degrees out and he refused
to put on a jacket
by the end of the evening i think he
regretted it but he'd never say
he's a powerful guy he's a great guy he
loves everybody and they love him
mike kelly congressman
as well as state senator judy ward thank
you judy thank you
thank you very much thank you judy great
job you doing
we built the greatest economy in history
and now we're doing it again
make america great again again right
remember
make america great again again we did it
and now we got to do it again and it's
happening much faster than anybody could
have believed we increased
middle class family income over six
thousand dollars more than five times
the gains
in all eight years under the last
administration it's really something
right did you see the crowd that
president obama had today
nobody nobody showed up i thought they'd
have a little crowd didn't quite have a
crowd like this
no nobody showed up they said he's going
to start campaigning and i said who
barack hussein obama i said oh i said is
that good or bad because you know he
campaigned harder than hillary the last
time how did that work out it didn't
work out
but he went to a few locations he's
averaging about
25 people he's averaging very low it's
disappointing
african-american unemployment hispanic
american unemployment
asian-american unemployment people with
diplomas from high school without
diplomas from high school college
diplomas
mit first in your class everybody was
employed
women women had the best they've had in
71 years
all reached their lowest levels ever
recorded
since april we created a record never
happened before
11.4 million jobs just april
we achieved the most secure border
because of the wall largely and
mexico has 27 000 troops at our border
protecting it for us i said you got to
do that
good man president of mexico good man
my opponent's insane immigration plan
would eliminate u.s borders by
implementing
nationwide catch and release that's
where you catch a killer
and you release them into our country
and we say come back in four years you
have a court case
and remember joe at the debate he said
oh they come back they don't come back
only the ones with the extraordinarily
low iq come back
nobody comes back they don't come back
we never took that one up but remember
we had a little argument about it he
said they come back they don't come back
making every community a sanctuary city
for violent criminals we're not going to
do that
they want sanctuary cities for violent
criminals
the biden harris plan would also
increase refugees 700
from the most dangerous places in the
world they pledged to terminate
all national security travel bans i have
a travel ban it was very tough
people didn't like it i said no thank
you i don't want people that want to
come into our country
and blow up our stores and our streets
and our people
and i put in a very strong travel ban
and we won in court we won at the united
states supreme court
you don't mind
and we keep out radical islamic
terrorists
we keep them out we invested 2.5
trillion dollars in our u.s
military 2.5 trillion with a t
with a t see joe would say
we invested 2.5 million dollars
said no it's trillion oh it is oh i
didn't know
you know the worst is when he constantly
is saying that number one he's running
for the u.s senate
i'm a proud democrat running for the u.s
senate thank you very much
that's only happened three times but the
worst of all is what he says like
tonight it's great to be in the state of
ohio
no no joe you're in pennsylvania no no
it's ohio isn't it
or when he was in idaho and he said iowa
it's great to be in iowa no no it's
idaho
potatoes remember potato idaho potato
or when he's in miami with the trees
beautiful palm trees
and he says he's in vermont it's great
to be in the state of vermont
and your palm trees all over the place
and i always say if you ever do that
when you're speaking i haven't done it
yet think of it in four and a half years
if you ever do that just walk off the
stage because there's nothing you can do
to make up for
you can be the great winston churchill
you know he's a great orator
winston churchill wouldn't make any
difference they say the speech was a
disaster
we also passed va choice and va
accountability
and exactly one year ago today we killed
the leader
of isis blood thirsty al-baghdadi
and we took out the number one terrorist
in the world
salamani is dead
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal think of it 1.5 think
of it
gave 1.8 billion in cash 150
billion for nothing we got nothing in
that deal
in fact the deal would be almost
terminating now short-term deal
what were they thinking of john kerry
remember he went into a bicycle race he
broke his arm on his leg
i kept saying leave the table leave the
table get up and negotiate tough leave
the table so he left
went in a bicycle race he didn't come
back for two months
should have stayed that much longer than
that what a deal that was
and we terminated it and iran now is
having a very bad time and you know the
first person that's going to call me
after we win
the heads of iran because they're losing
a fortune and i don't want that to
happen but they cannot have
a nuclear weapon they cannot
they'll call and make a deal i said you
better wait you better wait till after
the election let's
do it right i recognized the true
capital of israel and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem every
president
said they were going to do it every
president for decades and decades said
they were going to do it wasn't that
easy
it was tough once you get in there
there's a lot of opposition you get to
doing it
but we did it we got it done after many
many years instead of
never-ending wars we're forging peace in
the middle east
no cost and no blood right no cost and
no blood
now it's amazing amazing you saw three
countries now and we have
countries lined up to get in the deal
and they all said you couldn't do it
this way i reversed it because it wasn't
working
i reversed it and we just did sudan
uae bahrain and there's a lot of
countries they'll all be in there l.a no
blood in the sand
no blood mike no blood in the sand no
costs no
nothing they've been fighting that stuff
for so many years they all want to see
if they can do something
a vote for republicans is a vote and i
mean truly a vote for the republican
it's a
vote for the american dream if you think
about it
it's the american dream it's the
american dream
you know with the party of abraham
lincoln a lot of people don't know that
the great abraham lincoln the man that
i've always competed against i said
i can be more presidential than any
president
ever except for the possible exception
of abraham lincoln when he's wearing the
hat
that can be actually it'll be easy much
easier than what i do
it'd be much easier but we wouldn't have
quite this audience which goes back to a
point where you can't even see it i'd
love to have the camera show it
but they don't want to do that they
don't want to do that they don't want to
show it
i don't want to show this crowd because
it'll look like we're having too much
success and they don't want that
so in conclusion over the next four
years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
we're already doing it
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
[Music]
second amendment your second amendment
under siege but we've got it
we've got it okay for you we will end
surprise
medical billing require price
transparency a big deal it's already
signed goes into effect on january 1st
bigger than health care you watch
lower drug prices even more and we will
always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
always
right they agree
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our schools we're
already there
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag always
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
pennsylvania standing up
for the last four years you have seen me
fight for you
and now i am relying on you to deliver
another historic victory for our country
on november 3rd or sooner we must finish
the job and drain the swamp it's deeper
and more vicious than we thought but we
got them on the run
boy do we have them on the run think of
it they spied on our campaign it's our
campaign
they spied what they did to us and this
new one is just incredible i say it's
number two
number one they spied on our campaign
and then they try to harm
a duly elected president and then they
talk about peaceful transition
know what we did and the fact that we
were able to catch him and fight him and
beat him and we know everything about
him
watch what happens just watch what
happens get your friends
get your family get your neighbors get
your co-workers
and get out to vote you gotta vote
[Music]
you gotta get out to vote from allentown
to altoona
from erie to easton and from pittsburgh
to right
here in martinsburg we stand with the
shoulders
you like this location huh we stand on
the shoulders
of pennsylvania patriots who gave their
blood sweat and tears for this
beloved nation this is the state
where our founding fathers declared
american independence think of
pennsylvania think of what you've done
think of how important it is it's where
the army weathered its brutal winter at
valley forge
valley forge where general george
washington
they will not be touching the washington
monument i promise
let his men on a daring mission across
the delaware
and where our union was saved by the
heroes of gettysburg what history
this is a place where generations of
tough
strong pennsylvania workers mined the
call
worked the railroads and forged the
steel that made america into the
greatest and most powerful nation
in the history of the world and we are
making it
stronger and stronger every single day
proud citizens like you help build this
country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive we are going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together with the incredible people of
pennsylvania
we have made america powerful again
our military never been a military like
we have
we have made america wealthy again
401ks stock market
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you pennsylvania thank
you very much
[Music]
there's no need
[Music]
and i'm sure you will find
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
are you listening to me
[Applause]
[Music]
does it all by himself
put your friend on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take a walk up the street it's a
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the high mca
it's time
[Music]
is
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all myself
[Music]
[Music]
blue
[Music]
music
[Music]
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus reach
out in the streets
and then tickets are gone
[Music]
turning back
she's just
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign